just after 20 to 3 the duke of
edinburgh's coffin will be carried from
the state entrance of windsor castle
the queen's company first battalion
grenadier guards will place the coffin
on a specially modified land rover which
prince philip helped design
at 2 45 the procession will set off
led by the chiefs of the armed forces
and other senior military figures
it'll pass to the north side of the
round tower
followed on foot by the prince of wales
and other members of the royal family
the queen will be driven in the state
bentley
the route will be lined with
representatives from the royal navy
royal marines the highlanders 4th
battalion royal regiment
and the royal air force minute guns will
be fired from the east lawn of the
castle
by the king's royal horse artillery and
the bells of the curfew tower will tow
the rifles regiment will provide a guard
of honour and banned to play the
national anthem
as the coffin enters horseshoe cloister
before coming to a stop at the foot of
the chapel steps
at 2 53 the royal marines bearer party
will carry the coffin to the chapel
porch where it will pause at 3 pm
as a national minute silence is held
the dean of windsor and the archbishop
of canterbury will then receive prince
philip's coffin
inside saint george's chapel and the
service will begin
the congregation in saint george's
chapel will be made up of 30 people with
the queen
likely to be sitting alone to meet
social distancing rules
a small choir of four people will sing
pieces of music
chosen by the duke of edinburgh there
will be no
congregational singing at the end of the
service prince philip's coffin will be
lowered into the royal vault
beneath the chapel choir